when it comes to uh the the
Marketplace for dating and mating it's
interesting and I've talked a lot about
this a lot on my show uh and so let's go
way back to the 1950s for example and
think about if uh you were in government
in the 50s or if you were in the
corporatocracy in the 50s right these
two different groups uh if you're in
government you think well we had this
baby boom post-world War II uh it's been
great for the economy and you know by
the late 50s it's starting to Peter out
and we got to keep the economy going
increase the GDP we got almost half the
country's population
at home not producing any tax revenue
not growing the economy doing domestic
work
um and if we could figure out a way
to make them get into the workforce
we could grow the economy and that would
be good for getting reelected and if
we're in the corporatocracy and we've
got consumer products that we want to
sell
if we could get people to be discontents
to uh you know maybe keep them single or
if they're married make them discontent
so they would split up we could sell
them two toasters instead of one toaster
two coffee makers instead of one coffee
maker two sofas instead of one sofa uh
you know if you have two households you
basically doubled your market share of
virtually every product on Earth
practically right because you're not
sharing things like couples and families
do correct so I believe this is a uh a a
very much and I don't want to use the c
word conspiracy but it you know I mean
look at it conspiracy is nothing more
than people planning things right more
than one person planning something there
you know so what what has happened to
our culture uh in in where are we now
yeah you're giving them a lot of credit
um I know exactly where you're going
maybe too much maybe too much I don't
know I mean could there be a room full
of uh Elites sitting there that you know
that had planned this out maybe maybe
it's just a coincidence this is where we
are today but yeah it's it's you know
it's it's awfully obvious to me as well
that that's that's pretty much what
happened that led us to where we are
today you know the uh the fabric of the
nuclear family has been torn apart
um women were thrust in the workforce uh
they don't need any man anymore uh you
know divorce rates start to Sky
Skyrocket no fault uh you know divorce
comes in play uh you get the different
waves of feminism that sort of follow
with that and we end up in an
environment today where
um we've got
confusion around who's the mommy and
who's the daddy and uh you know anything
can happen right there's you know the re
they're rewriting the rule book and
everything I was just filling out a um
application to get my uh daughter's
passport renewed and it was indicating
stuff on there that I haven't seen
before yeah right uh you know it doesn't
say mother or father anymore now it says
parent or in one area where it was an
older form it actually said with an
attachment
um you know if you don't like that term
uh then just cross it out and put parent
instead of mother or for the record we
should mention you're a Canadian so yes
yes this is this is the way that Justin
Trudeau's Canada is heading in fact
um yeah so that's what's uh so that's
what's been going on
um where's it going probably going to
continue in that direction is what I'm
seeing yeah I really hope you guys
enjoyed that clip if you want to watch
the full length podcast you can find
that over here that clips from if you're
new to the channel make sure you hit
subscribe over here and pin down below
in the top comment you'll find a bunch
of useful links to my website my
supplement line books and a bunch of
other stuff uh have an amazing day peace
out